I see you trample workers down in the
state I love life I guess the voice of
democracy isn't enough so you Fitzgerald
- ever since he took on Wisconsin's
teachers unions and denied them
collective bargaining rights Republican
Governor Scott Walker has been public
enemy number one for public sector
unions Walker faces a recall election on
June 5th and may well be chased out of
the governor's mansion after just one
year in office but is Walker the
Heartless budget cutter his opponents
claim slashing spending cutting taxes
and driving Wisconsin's economy into a
sinkhole hardly here are 3 lies at the
heart of the Wisconsin recall my budget
strategy is simple slap Walker has cut
the rate of which spending is growing
but he hasn't actually cut spending in
fact the state's biennial budget is
scheduled to increase by about 3 percent
on Walker's watch a big reason for that
is that Walker is overseeing a historic
increase in state spending on Medicaid
which is the government's health
insurance program for the poor Walker
has cut state aid to schools which he
says will be paid for by cost-saving
measures such as requiring teachers to
kick in more for their pensions in
health care but the bottom line is that
Walker hasn't actually cut overall state
spending
Scott Walker you're a hypocrite your
budget bill ain't worth a spit first
governor that we will fire Scott Walker
you're a bald-faced liar
governor Walker's tax cuts will save
Wisconsinites about 136 million dollars
next fiscal year
but that's only about 1% of the total
tax money the state collects it's not
like Wisconsin is some sort of
undertaxed Haven in 2009 the Tax
Foundation ranked Wisconsin is having
the 4th highest combined state and local
tax burden in the country if cutting
taxes and letting individuals spend
their own money as a way to spark
economic activity Wisconsin still has a
long way to go and this week a new
report reveals that the state of
Wisconsin lost more jobs than any other
state in the country
that's the decrease not an increase
governor the worst jobs record in the
country Walker is being battered for a
projected drop of 24,000 jobs in the
Badger State over the course of one year
his supporters are pointing to another
study that shows an increase of 23,000
jobs during Walker's first year in
office whichever is more accurate these
numbers represent neither catastrophe
nor triumph since they represent less
than 1% of Wisconsin's entire labor
force and one thing both sides can agree
on is that Wisconsin's unemployment rate
of 6.8% is well below the national
average Wisconsin's economy has plenty
of room for improvement but that'll only
happen if Governor Walker can get
serious about cutting spending and taxes
for reason TV I'm Nikolas
you try to Buster you and try to take
away our rights you thought you could do
it like deep in the night